an emotionally charged gathering outside
the supreme court of honduras
many hope to catch a glimpse of former
honduran president juan orlando
hernandez wanted by u.s authorities on
international drug trafficking and
illegal weapons charges
hernandez arrived in handcuffs and
chains for a preliminary court hearing
related to an extradition request filed
by the united states earlier this week
we are here to celebrate we're here to
celebrate the narco dictatorship that is
failing today with its greatest leader
tensions outside the court led to minor
scuffles between critics and supporters
of the former president
we are supporting our president in peace
so a dignified process is carried out
and his rights are respected we are also
supporting him peacefully as the
national party as leaders of the party
we are not looking for trouble we are
not attacking anyone we just want our
president to realise he's not alone
hernandez was arrested on tuesday at his
home in the honduran capital u.s
prosecutors allege hernandez helped
facilitate the trafficking of hundreds
of tons of narcotics from colombia and
venezuela over the course of his eight
years as president allegations the 53
year old former hunter and leader has
repeatedly
denied his fate now in the hands of a
judge overseeing a request for
extradition by the united states
in order to guarantee his presence at
the extradition proceedings he will be
provisionally detained at the facilities
of the special operations command of the
national police
federal prosecutors in new york had
previously named hernandez a
co-conspirator in a major international
drug trafficking case
and last year a u.s judge sentenced
president hernandez's younger brother
tony hernandez to life in prison over
charges related to cocaine trafficking
having concluded the first of two
appearances before the supreme court
former honduran president juan orlando
hernandez will remain under the custody
of security forces until march 16th for
a second and final extradition hearing
manuel rapalo al jazeera tegucigalpa